the pirate bay is likely one of the most
infamous websites in the world ever
since it launched in 2003 the pirate bay
has been one of the top places to pirate
movies software and games as you would
guess this has enraged copyright holders
and prosecutors who have been trying to
shut down the site and punish pirates
but despite how many times they take it
down it seems like it's always just a
matter of time until the site is back up
and running
considering this you would think that
the key to solving the issue is
addressing the root problem by taking
down the founders but prosecutors have
tried this as well they chased the
founders across the world threw them in
jail and charged them with every
copyright infringement charge you can
think of yet the pirate bay still lives
on in fact one of the founders is
actually happy to do jail time in order
to keep the pirate bay alive so here's
how the pirate bay came to life what
happened to the founders and why
prosecutors have struggled to take it
down
taking a look back the origins of the
pirate bay date back to a swedish
organization called piratebiron which
means the piracy bureau as the name
suggests the organization focused on
legalizing piracy through political
connections petitioning and lobbying
most people at the organization felt
that information should be allowed to
freely spread across the internet and
they questioned the idea of intellectual
property in fact some of these guys
would even argue that piracy is helpful
to companies because it gets expensive
software and games into the hands of
people who would have otherwise never
tried it and once they get addicted to
the said game or software they're much
more likely to actually buy it the
second or third time around
now i would never argue that piracy is
moral but there's no doubt that software
like windows adobe's creative cloud and
even grand theft auto wouldn't be nearly
as popular as they are today without
piracy this line of reasoning was
basically the framework of pirate biron
and in september of 2003 they would
decide to take it to the next level
three pyrote beyond employees named
peter sonde god fritz swartham and
frederick nage launched a file sharing
website called the pirate bay the idea
was inspired by bittorrent which made
its debut a few years before this
originally the pirate bay was run out of
servers in mexico godfred convinced his
employer who had service in mexico to
help them run the site but it didn't
take long for his employer to back off
so the founders were forced to bring the
site back home and gottfried ran it
using his pentium 3 laptop which only
had 256 megabytes of ram despite the
basic setup given the limited number of
file sharing sites back in 2003 it
didn't take long for pirates to flood in
by the end of 2004 the pirate bay saw a
total of a 1 million users and 60 000
files being shared as the site grew the
trio expanded their operations by
getting servers and databases and they
transformed their laptop service into an
international hub for file sharing and
by 2006 everything under the sun was
being shared on the site whether that be
music in movies or software and games
and to make things worse the pirate bay
wasn't even trying to distance
themselves from these activities some
other popular piracy sites like mega and
z try to put up a good guy persona in
order to minimize trouble with the law
but this wasn't the case with the pirate
bay these guys were proud to enable free
information sharing across the internet
and they had no intention of hiding
behind some fake persona
and this attitude became extremely
apparent to authorities after they sent
out dozens of copyright infringement and
seasoned desist notices which resulted
in no action from the founders the
police tried to just ignore the site for
many years but as the site continued to
grow in popularity they started to
receive more and more pressure to take
it down and in 2006 they finally decided
to crack down
i'm sure the founders always expected
trouble with the authorities given the
nature of what they were doing but i'm
not sure if they expected the force at
which prosecutors would hit back on may
31 2006 65 police officers raided the
pirate-based data center and shut down
their servers none of the founders were
arrested but it was made pretty clear
that the site should not be restarted as
you would guess though the founders
ignored these demands they went ahead
and got new servers in an unspecified
location in the netherlands and the
pirate bay was back up and running
within just three days not only did the
raid not take down the website but it
actually led to more people using the
website you see it the police raid
became international news and even the
new york times ran a story about it
aside from driving more users to the
website these news articles fueled an
international movement amongst internet
nerds one hacker went ahead and hacked
into sweden's national police website
policin.sc and it took down the website
and just as the police website was
restored the government website was
taken down
clearly these were extremely
irresponsible moves but they definitely
made a statement shortly after the raid
the pirate bay grew to be the 465th most
visited website in the world and some
lawyers even jumped onto the foundry
side the lawyers accused the police of
unfailing pounding every server in sight
during the raid you see it the servers
that were impounded weren't only
responsible for running the pirate bay
but also responsible for running dozens
of small websites and businesses so the
police had wronged all these businesses
in the name of taking down one website
the lawyers also argued that the swedish
police didn't have a justifiable reason
to conduct a raid in the first place
they accused the swedish government of
giving in american political pressure
instead of carrying out law and order
the government of course strongly denied
these charges and these cases didn't
really go anywhere but the government
had a nightmare dealing with all this
unexpected negative pr
initially they expected that they would
be hailed as the heroes fighting against
piracy but instead they were made out to
be the villains the thing is most people
have pirated media or software at some
point during their lives statistically
52 percent of online users have watched
pirated videos even though 59 of users
are aware that downloading and streaming
pirated videos is illegal and that's
just the people who admitted to it as a
result when the news came out that the
pirate bay had been taken down it was
not like the average person was jumping
up and down in excitement the more
realistic reaction was probably oh well
it was nice while it lasted considering
this only a very small portion of people
went out of their way to support the
swedish government's actions and without
large public support the government
couldn't just raid the pirate bay again
because that would just increase its
popularity even more so they decided to
address the route by taking down the
founders
on april 17 2009 the three founders
peter frederick and gottfried as well as
the server provider carl lundstrom were
found guilty of assistance to copyright
infringement and were each sentenced to
one year in prison they were also
ordered to pay a fine worth 30 million
swedish kroner or 4.3 million dollars
the squad appealed the verdict arguing
that sweden gave into political pressure
this actually decreased each of their
sentences by a few months but it
increased to 5 to 46 million kroner or
6.6 million dollars this didn't really
matter to the founders though as they
had no intention of paying the fine
peter actually held up a sign during the
press conference to follow the verdict
that said i owe you 31 million kroner he
followed up this statement by suggesting
that this was all the government was
going to get he claimed that he didn't
have any money and even if he did he'd
rather burn everything and not even give
them the ashes in terms of the arrest
though carl and peter didn't really
resist much further and they simply gave
in but the same could not be said about
godford and frederick who went on the
run gottfried ran away to cambodia which
had no extradition policy to sweden but
despite the policy the cambodian police
arrested gottfried on august 30 2012 and
deported him back to sweden there's been
some speculation that sweden and
cambodia had an insider deal to
extradite godfred just six days after
godfrey was arrested the swedish
government announced a 400 million
kronor grant for cambodia so it is
awfully suspicious but all we can do is
speculate once godfred was back in
sweden he served his your sentence at
the mary fred prison but the police
didn't just stop right there they also
piled on hacking and fraud charges which
led to a total three-year sentence but
eventually in september of 2015
gottfried was released and finally as
for frederick he was able to pay the
police for even longer than godfred he
had fled to leo's slashed island and he
had built a life in both of these
countries honestly i don't know why he
didn't just choose one or the other as
this dual life resulted in him crossing
the border on a regular basis and during
one of these border crossings in
november of 2014 he was arrested and
deported fortunately for frederick his
prison sentence was far less severe than
gottfried's coming in at 10 months
frederick actually claims that prison
wasn't even that bad and that it was
well worth it for the pirate bay
apparently he was the only one in the
prison that was there for a virtual
crime so the guards weren't as tough on
him he says that he was able to smuggle
in usb sticks with movies on them and
watch them on his prison tv he did miss
his friends and family but he received
dozens of letters from fans of the
pirate bay which he says helped him get
through the 10 months anyway now that
all the founders were behind bars the
police could finally shut down the
pirate bay once and for all or so they
thought
on december 9 2014 the swedish police
braided the pirate bay once again and
impounded all of their servers computers
and equipment with the founders out of
the game this must be the end right well
just four days after the pirate bay was
taken down a torrent site called isohunt
launched a website called
oldpiratebay.org which mirrored all the
content on the pirate bay and this is
when the prosecutors realized that they
had lost the game forever here's the
thing the piratebay doesn't actually
host any files themselves they just
connect peers from around the world
using links so all the pirate bay is
storing is links the contents of the
entire website can be stored within a
gigabyte if not less and there are
thousands of people making copies of the
website on a daily basis so even if
authorities take down one copy of the
site it's not very difficult to upload a
gigabyte of data to a new server and get
a new domain and that's why it's
impossible to truly take down the pirate
bay considering this prosecutors have
basically given up on taking down the
pirate bay as there's simply no single
person to hold accountable in the
meantime copyright holders have shifted
their efforts to working with internet
service providers to cut internet to
pirates but this has just left the
pirates using vpns anyway as for the
founders today peter went ahead and
founded a patreon type service called
flatter instead of donating to creators
though the service is used to donate to
websites and projects that better
society and reveal corruption like
wikileaks aside from flatter peter has
also given several speeches and
interviews regarding his various views
on the world gottfried and frederick on
the other hand don't have nearly as big
of a public image in fact they have no
public presence at all and they simply
disappeared into the depths of the
internet after frederick was released he
said that he was going to get an i.t job
and settle in laos so that's presumably
what he's doing now and that's what
happened to the pirate base founder and
why the pirate bay can never be taken
down do you guys think piracy is moral
comment that down below also drop a like
if you've ever downloaded something that
you shouldn't have and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you